[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est ravi de l'accueillir et demie
vite comment allez-vous fin ça va ça va
un peu grippé mais on essaye c'est sage
d'être au ballon d'alsace de prendre le
bon air et où il faut s'habiller
chaudement je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller départemental dans le canton
de masevaux avec votre binôme fabienne
orlandi et alors ce soir on va emmener
nos téléspectateurs faire le plein de
poudreuse pile poil au sommet là où vous
êtes et père d'une petite crève au
ballon d'alsace sont des paysages qui
sont tout simplement magnifiques ce sont
des sports d'hiver une balade en
traîneau mais pas que reportage d'adrien
la vie c'est parti
bienvenue dans le canton de masevaux ce
territoire en forme de croissant s'étend
au sud ouest du département il est
assurément le plus beau d'alsace selon
ses habitants nous ne prendrons bien sûr
pas partie mais il est évident qu'il
rassemble sur son territoire toute la
diversité des paysages de notre belle
région au sud entre maisons à colombages
prairies et lacs images typiques du
sundgau et dès que le regard porte vers
le nord le massif des vosges est là pour
nous rappeler que la montagne n'est pas
bien long c'est justement là que nous
nous rendons au fond de la vallée de la
deûle air au pied du ballon d'alsace
[Musique]
nous nous trouvons sur le barrage du lac
d'alfeld qui est donc propriété du
département qui sert de retenue d'eau
qui sert l'été pour les th2 l'ado l'air
ça permet de toujours fournir de l'eau
donc pour la consommation humaine mais
aussi pour préserver toute la faune qui
se trouve dans la rivière qui pourrait
se retrouver à sec sinon la doller
aliments tout le bassin mulhousiens pour
l'eau potable qui arrive au robinet
c'est également dans ceux là que l'on
pompe l'eau qui sert pour les canons à
neige au ballon d'alsace
[Musique]
culminant à 1247 m le sommet du ballon
d'alsace est à cheval sur trois
départements
on y trouve une station de sports
d'hiver qui fait le bonheur des familles
mais aussi des amateurs de glisse plus
exigeants avec l'une des plus belles
pistes noires d'alsace depuis 2009 la
station concentre toutes les attentions
des collectivités locales réaménagement
des pistes installations de téléski elle
est gérée par le smiba syndicat mixte
interdépartemental du ballon d'alsace
qui regroupe les départements du
haut-rhin et du territoire de belfort
ainsi que les collectivités de par et
d'autres du sommet c'est lui qui a en
charge donc tous les bâtiments qui est
propriétaire de pas mal de foncier de
terrain de piste et c'est lui qui donc
organisent toute la station alors ça
fonctionne surtout l'hiver pour les
sports d'hiver mais notre but c'est
aussi de développer le tourisme quatre
saisons de le bus et d'aménager vraiment
cette partie du ballon pour des
activités été et hiver
retour dans la poudreuse le temps d'une
petite balade en traîneau avec la meute
scooby doo ou comment découvrir ce site
classé en se prenant pour un explorateur
du grand nord afin de valoriser ce
patrimoine naturel les collectivités
agissent pour obtenir le classement
grands sites du ballon d'alsace de quoi
s'agit-il fabienne orlandi nous en dit
plus ce sont des lieux emblématiques qui
sont superbes souvent du point de vue
paysager et qui vise donc à aménager le
lieu pour le préserver malgré un nombre
important de touristes
donc on préserve la nature mais en même
temps on favorise le tourisme et
l'activité économique sur le sommet et
en piémont dans les vallées ce qu'on
cherche vraiment c'est à faire connaître
le ballon d'alsace au niveau national et
international
[Musique]
le ballon venait à obtenir ce classement
au même titre que la camargue où la baie
de somme il serait le premier du
grand-est être ainsi labellisés un coup
de projecteur sur le ballon d'alsace qui
ne manquera pas de profiter à tous
[Musique]
voilà magnifique ballon d'alsace rémy
vite je rappelle vous êtes le conseil
départemental dans le canton de mas go
on a parlé de ce classement grand site
est-ce que depuis ce tournage est ce qu
on a eu deux des nouvelles fait des
nouvelles toutes fraîches ou est ce que
madame ségolène royal vient de nous
confirmer sa part écrit qu' elle
retenait la candidature pour le
classement grands sites excellence est
une bonne bonne nouvelle est surtout une
première phase puisque maintenant il va
falloir travailler pour la deuxième
phase qui elle ce sera la constitution
du cahier des charges pour le classement
proprement dit voilà le travail commence
maintenant mais vous l'avez obtenu chez
que vous vous battiez depuis le 2 avril
2015 le canton de maso a été redessiné
puisqu'il réunit aujourd'hui beaucoup de
cantons c'est un défi
difficile pour vous à gérer ce très
grand canton aujourd'hui écoutés 7 c'est
effectivement un canton qui est
peut-être pas parmi les plus peuplées de
du haut rhin mais le plus étirés
effectivement il ya 80 km qui séparent
un coin à une extrémité du canton à
l'autre notamment depuis la frontière
suisse a fait trousses jusqu'au ballon
d'alsace au pied de au dessus de ses
veines quoi donc fallait donc 80 km et
oui il faut les faire mais un défi
effectivement mais c'est un défi
fantastique parce que avec une bonne
organisation pour notre binôme avec une
complémentarité nous pouvons être figaro
efficace et puis à différents endroits
presque en même temps donc c'est
remarquable les images parlent d'elles
mêmes dans le reportage c'est
incroyablement beau chez vous est ce là
la richesse de notre territoire les
paysages à les paysages c'est
l'essentiel c'est vrai bon il ya aussi
les hommes qui habitent ce territoire
mais mais les paysages vous l'avez dit
les images sans sont belles mais en
toutes les saisons en été comme en hiver
et justement au delà entre la montagne
la plaine les rivières et là que les
forêts les prairies et les vergers enfin
bref les maisons à colombages enfin on a
mis tout ça
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
fantastique et nous sommes très heureux
de pouvoir être présent dans ce canton
pour porter haut et fort l'authenticité
de ce canton auquel tiennent les
habitants du territoire et bientôt le
classement grands sites pour ce ballon
d'alsace arh qui court dans la
préservation du territoire il ya le
collège nathan katz de burnhaupt-le-haut
qui est également un exemple d'endroits
de collèges éco responsable d'eads et
développement durable c'est important
pour vous tout à fait on a été de tout
temps je crois précurseur et pionnier
dans le développement durable d'ailleurs
la preuve les paysages le montre bien
s'ils sont restés intacts c'est bien
parce qu'on a été respectueux de cet
environnement et collège de burnhaupt
est un exemple précis qui a été
construit en 2009 par le conseil
départemental le département
le bâtiment est à ossature bois le
plancher bois là le chauffage et est
aubois donc la filière bois est vraiment
présente du début à la fin et puis je
dirais la toiture a été imaginé aussi
pourrait être un coupe-vent aux vents
dominants et pour laisser pénétrer toute
la lumière naturelle dans les
différentes salles de classe tout est
étrange tout a été pensé du moins à
cette époque comme éco construction et
en même temps développement durable à
l'époux roquelaure autre aspect
environnemental et ça aujourd'hui on
sait que nombreux conseils
départementaux ils sont attachés c'est
les circuits courts voilà il ya rien
mieux que ça on en parle beaucoup au
niveau national sauf que dans votre
territoire chez vous c'est déjà une
réalité les siens il y à il ya une bonne
expérience qui est menée à gommersdorf
avec le baudelet les poignée
d'agriculteurs a décidé un jour de
prendre le problème à bras le corps et
ont créé cette filière du baudelaire et
donc c'est quoi le voudrait bien cesser
le veau le vaudois ferme qui est élevé
uniquement au lait de vaches de la ferme
et donc il est laid et engrossé et puis
ensuite quand il a le poids qu'il faut
il est emmené à l'abattoir de cernay qui
est un autre outil de proximité que le
département a réalisé pour justement
permettre aux éleveurs d'avoir une
solution pour leur filière courte tête
les images qu'on voit là que l'abattoir
where we est justement cet abattoir
permet de conditionner
les la viande en caissettes pour le
consommateur directement pour le
consommateur c'est donc cessé un
filières courtes le producteur au
consommateur c'est bon bien du côté de
mazo merci beaucoup rémy